hallo wir machen heute einen
familienausflug papiere sind wir
ich glaube wir sind in lübbenau im
spreewald wenn ihr mal nach berlin kommt
und ihr möchtet gern etwas natur sehen
außerhalb der stadt dann könntet ihr zum
beispiel einen ausflug in den spreewald
machen das ist ein bekanntes
naturschutzgebiet und wir sehen uns
jetzt heute hier um los geht's
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
wir sind heute in lübbenau das ist eine
stadt im spreewald und wir sind hier
hingefahren mit dem zug
die fahrt hat eine stunde gedauert von
berlin aus
[Musik]
der spreewald ist bekannt für seine
spreewaldgurken deshalb gibt es im
spreewald nicht nur gurken zum essen
sondern auch guten aufkleber gurken
magnete gurken tassen und stromkästen
mit gurken so leute ich habe gedacht wir
fangen mal unser abenteuer im spreewald
mit einem gurken schnaps an
er wird probieren doch jetzt ist doch
was
[Musik]
ist ja jetzt noch eine gurke dabei sehr
perfekt
[Musik]
eine besonders beliebte aktivität hier
im spreewald sind bootstouren man kann
selber boote mieten oder sich fahren
lassen denn es gibt hier ganz viele
wasserstraßen und man nennt die wie ich
gerade gelernt habe fließe das heißt das
sind natürliche flüsse und fluss
verzweigungen und darauf kann man fahren
wie auf einer wasserstraße der fährmann
erzählt uns gerade das ist hier eine
insel gibt zwischen den fließen
und da drauf stehen grundstücke also da
sind häuser die nur per wasser zu
erreichen sind und es gibt sogar einen
post kann der jeden tag post und pakete
ausliefert per wasser
[Musik]
easyjet fans aus indonesien getroffen
mitten im wald
[Musik]
welche ist die liga kommt das ist die
gurke und das ist salz bild wenn es auch
probieren ja von dir sind klein ist in
hessen ist gar nicht da hat auch ein
bisschen ein bisschen ja ziemlich
während mein mund noch von den chilligen
brennt geht janisch zur fischräucherei
er will sich ein brötchen kaufen online
ja nur spanisch hat sich nicht nur ein
fischbrötchen gekauft sondern einen
ganzen fisch und er macht sich jetzt mit
seinem brötchen und den fisch so selber
ein fischbrötchen wir mal mama und papa
ihr wart vor 18 jahren schon mal hier im
spreewald wie hat sich der spreewald
seitdem verändert
der spreewald ist wesentlich
touristischer geworden als er vor 18
jahren hier wollen nach schnee es war
auch ein karsamstags aber die bootstour
war genau so beschaulich wie sie heute
machen ja der ort hat sich völlig
verändert
die häuser sind alle erneuert worden der
ort ist modernisiert worden
nach zehn jahren sei das war völlig
anders jahres das war unsere episode aus
dem spreewald wenn ihr mal in berlin
seit und für einen tag dem stadtlärm
entkommen möchtet dann empfehlen wir
euch einen ausflug hierhin zu machen
und wenn er jetzt noch weiter deutsch
lernen möchte unter anderem mit dem
quatsch den janisch so macht dann schaut
doch mal bei unserer app ceiling vorbei
dort könnt ihr mit interaktiven video
geschichten deutsch lernen und wir
freuen uns wenn ihr das ausprobiert
tschüss und bis zur nächsten woche
[Musik]